- Well, welcome everyone.
It's really great to see so
many of you in the Zoom room
and I wanna thank you on behalf
of the department of
African-American studies
for making the time to
think and to critique
and to plan with us in what
has been an extraordinary set
of seminars this past semester
that we've devoted to
really thinking about
and learning about new modes of activism
to address the crises
that are shaping our time.
We thought about elections
and voting rights
which are still haunting and
aching at us as we speak.
We've been thinking about healthcare
and as a justice movement especially
for formerly incarcerated people.
We've been thinking about
the role of art and artists
in protests and social justice movements,
and today and in the
next and final session
that we'll be hosting this semester,
we're gonna be thinking
about the histories,
the cultural logics, the
institutional practices and agents
that manage the carceral state,
and to think about how we dismantle it
or to use a phrase that I was reminded
of teaching James Baldwins great novel
about this very crisis, "If
Beale Street Could Talk",
how do we take apart, the jaws
of this democratic hell called the prison,
called the police state?
So, that's our discussion today.
My colleague Crystal Feimster
will introduce our panelists shortly.
I just want to point to
the next conversation
we'll be having about this topic
on December 10th after
Thanksgiving break at 11:45.
Our colleague Elizabeth Hinton,
wonderful brilliant
historian of the history
of mass incarceration
will be in conversation
with Tracey Meares, our colleague
in ally in the law school
and they'll be talking about the work
that the Justice Collaboratory
that's housed in the law school.
They'll explain that group's work
and we can open up how we
might partner with them
in the great work that they're doing.
I wanna give thanks, excuse me, here to,
you know, nothing can
happen without collaboration
in the age of Zoom especially,
and I wanna thank our
co-sponsor for these seminars,
the Center for the Study
of Race, Indigeneity
and Transnational Migration RITM,
the director Steve Pitti,
and the assistant director Matthew Tanico
have been just absolutely
wonderful partners
in organizing and helping us
mobilize these discussions
and I wanna thank them.
I wanna thank the staff
in African-American studies, Vanessa Epps,
our senior administrative assistant
who's been really wonderful in stepping up
and getting the word out
to bring you all here,
and to Immanuel Bissell
who has been our tech guru
making sure that everything works so well
on the backend of the Zoom room.
And I also wanna thank
especially my colleague Crystal Feimster
who teaches, she's a
brilliant brilliant historian
of African-American
history across the era.
So, I guess what's so
stunning to me about crystal
is that there's no period
that she does not know how
to engage and fully grasp it,
and she has been the brilliant mind
who's organizing curated the
panels for this semester.
So, I wanna thank her for her work
and her leadership on this
and I'll turn it over to her
to introduce our panelists.
- Thank you, Jackie.
But I wanna extend my gratitude
to all (mumbles) the folks
Vanessa and Immanuel as well.
It goes without saying
that it takes a village
and I couldn't do this without the support
of my chair Jackie Goldsby
and all of my colleagues
in African-American studies
and (mumbles) who have stepped
up to basically participate
in these conversations.
I wanna, before I introduce
our guests today I'd like
to remind you of the format and the format
is that we will have a conversation
between Phillip Goff and Philip McHarris
for about 45 to 50 minutes,
and then around four o'clock
we'll open up for Q and A.
We ask that you submit your questions
to Phil McHarris in the private chat link.
He'll moderate the Q and A
and try to consolidate some questions
so that we can get everybody's
questions in today.
Part of the reason we're
asking you to do that
is because we are filming and recording
so that this can be available
to folks who couldn't be here today.
And if you come in and out of the screen
it means we've got to get
permission to record you
or engage in some serious editing.
So, but having said
that we wanna make sure
that everybody who wants to participate
in the conversation can do so.
And on that note, I wanna
say it is both an honor
and a privilege to be able to present
and introduce two of my colleagues
in African-American studies.
I'll start with Phillip Atiba Goff,
I hope I said your middle name right.
(indistinct) names, but
I'mma say Atiba again
and then you can correct me later, okay.
As a professor of African-American studies
and psychology at Yale
University, yay, welcome,
and the co-founder and CEO
of the Center for Policing Equity,
a research and action think
tank on race and policing.
He is a leading scholar in
the science of racial bias
and has pioneered scientific experiments
that expose how our minds
learn to associate blackness
and crime implicitly often
with deadly consequences.
Dr. Goff has won two American
Psychological Association
early career awards,
the Association of Psychological
Science Rising Star Award
and the National Organization
of Black Law Enforcement
Executives Lloyd G Sealy Award
among many others.
He regularly appears on Cable news,
provides congressional testimony
and with a panelist for the
president Obama task force
on 21st century policing.
I'd like to turn to his
interlocutor today too
will be framing and
moderating our discussion,
and that is Phil McHarris,
who is a PhD candidate
in the joint program of
African-American studies
in sociology at Yale University, hi.
Phil's main area of research
include race and ethnicity,
housing, policing, and inequality.
His current research focuses
on the experience of residents
of a high rise public housing development
in Brooklyn, New York
as they navigate concerns
surrounding safety, policing,
building conditions and cycles of poverty.
In another line of his research,
Philip examined the causes
and consequences of the large
scale expansion of policing
in the United States since 1965
and the strategies that communities employ
to challenge police expansion
and police violence.
Philip draws on qualitative
and quantitative methods
throughout his research.
In addition to his scholarly
work, Philip has written
for outlets that include
the New York Times,
Washington Post and Slate.
His commentary has been featured
on HBO, CNN, Time and PBS.
Philip is a recipient
of the Ford Foundation
pre-doctoral Fellowship
and the NSF Graduate Research Fellowship.
Welcome and I'm gonna turn it
over to Phil M at this point.
- Well, I have to keep track
of the Phil M and Phil G,
but I'm thanking you for that actually.
Yeah, hello everyone,
it's a pleasure to be here
with you all today
and I'm eager to have this
discussion around policing.
I wanna offer a few points to
ground our conversation today.
But first I'm gonna lift up
all those who have gotten us
to a place where we can have conversations
around radically
re-imagining public safety
and ways for caring for one another.
To that end, I wanna lift up
the Movement for Black Lives
organization in Minneapolis,
namely Reclaim the Block,
Black Visions Collective
and MPD 150 and those in Ferguson
that on August 9th, 2014
decided enough was enough,
played a large role in
launching this iteration
of the long black freedom struggle.
We find ourselves at a
critical juncture in history
as it relates to policing
and public safety.
There's been a resurgence of
the Movement for Black Lives.
Over the last five years
organizers have been building
and developing politically
to bring us to a moment
where we can see and push for
much different set of demands.
Specifically the nation
has seen the injection
of abolitionists language and
demands to popular discourse
in ways that is unprecedented.
Abolitionists and those
calling for dramatic shrinking
and the scope and power of policing
have grown increasingly skeptical
of popular seemingly progressive reforms
that have been raised a solution
in recent years and decades.
Procedural justice, bias
training, community policing,
diversity efforts, use
of force guidelines,
civilian review boards, body cameras,
focused deterrents and training centered
on police legitimacy have all
been fundamentally called into question
as many municipalities
have enacted these reforms.
While the impacts of the
various strategies vary
from negligible to having some
impact on particular metrics,
they have proven ineffective
in stopping cycles
of police violence.
Abolitionists such as Angela
Davis, Ruth Wilson Gilmore,
Mariame Kaba and organizers
from Critical Resistance
and so many others have
offered black feminist visions
of the world that sees the
utter and complete dismantling
of systems of imprisonment,
policing and surveillance
and the creation of new ways of relating
and caring for one another,
leading to transformation
and ensuring communities
have their basic needs met
and the resources to thrive,
which has been so critical
to bringing us to the present
moment we find ourselves in
where we can have very different
kinds of conversations.
To be sure the persistent policing
of black and marginalized communities
is tied up in larger systems of racial
and class inequalities essentially
racial capitalism itself.
Those who have presented
visions of abolition
and reallocation have argued
for the start of the large scale reduction
and dismantling of punitive systems
in favor of the creation
of just, democratic
and non-coercive as Ruth
Wilson Gilmore states,
life affirming institutions.
Specifically, recent calls for defunding
which anti-violence organizer Mariame Kaba
has called a moderate demand
within a larger abolitionist framework
have called for the shift
of resources from policing
to the resources that have been proven
to increase safety in communities
including quality housing,
dignifying employment,
health care, resource schools
as well as alternative emergency
and crisis response systems.
Even more organizers have
called for a re-imagining
of the ways we address conflict, harm
and violence centered on frameworks
such as transformative justice
rather than punitive approaches
that have been so fine tuned
in America's carceral state.
And to ground us, I wanna center
in this conversation, all
those who are no longer with us
as a result of police violence,
those who have survived it
and all those, including
those on the front lines of protest
and organizing efforts that
continue to experience it
in order to bring about a
radically different society
and approach to public safety
than the one we see today.
And lastly, I also wanna hold all those
who are trapped in the
cages of incarceration
in the United States who
likely needed resources,
safe housing, mental health
treatment, care, support,
food, quality education,
meaningful employment
or arrested in front of, into
America's jails and prisons
as well as those who have
been jailed and incarcerated
throughout the country for protesting
and challenging state violence.
My hope is that we can route
this conversation today
in the long black freedom struggle
and the fight to end
cycles of premature death
and ensuring communities have
the resources and conditions
to live life more fully.
So, let's turn to the conversation.
Again, you know, I hope this conversation
can be a generative
and productive dialogue
that can bring us to having
a more sense of clarity
on all the words and concepts
we've heard over the past few months
from abolition to reform
to the funding and more.
And, you know, I probably
have more questions
than we have time for today,
but, you know, I imagine that
as mentioned, Professor Goff
and I will engage in conversation
for around 50 minutes or so
before we include questions.
So, let's start Professor Goff,
you know, you've been involved
in work around policing
for quite some time now,
can you flesh out a little
more what's CPE's work
and central area of focus look like?
- Sure, thank you for that.
Thank you for, Crystal.
Thank you, Jackie.
Thank you, Immanuel.
Thank you, Vanessa.
We've got about 40 other folk
on the call, thank all y'all.
There used to be a pretty pithy way
to try to explain what
CPE did nine months ago.
We said we work with communities
inside of law enforcement
to make them less deadly, less racist.
What we didn't say was
that the ultimate goal
was to make them smaller.
So, now I say that, plus
we work with communities
to make them smaller
outside of law enforcement.
The way that we're known to function
is we go into police departments
after asking communities,
all right, so what is it
that is your biggest set of concerns?
We get data from the police
department, combine it
with other psych data
that we collect ourselves
and/or census and crime data,
and that allows us to
draw a map essentially,
not just the racial disparities
and things like juvenile
detention, arrests,
use of force, stops, but the portion
of those disparities that
can reasonably be traced back
to law enforcement 'cause
the idea here is that
if black folks are let's
say four times more likely
to have force used on
them than white folks
in a given community, a skeptical chief
will come along and say
but that's just poverty.
That's just, what about
black and black crime?
And even if we don't assume
that that's a bad faith argument,
which it almost always is,
it's reasonable to go in and say,
all right, so if law
enforcers are supposed
to go where crime goes, let's
just take that as a given,
then that should add influence
and it turns out when you
start doing just the basics,
the most conservative tests
that argument falls flat
to explain a large
portion of the variance.
So, you simply defang
the argument and say,
do you have anything else?
If you don't and you would like
to make this better
here's where you can go.
The work that we're doing outside
of law enforcement now follows basically
the same principles, right?
Law enforcement says,
essentially in every sort
of municipality, every public hearing,
Department of Public Health
says, here's why you need us,
please keep funding us.
Private education says,
here's why you need us,
please keep funding us,
and law enforcement says,
fund us or you going to die.
They've not had to
justify why they're there.
So, we're able to go in and
say, here are the things
that law enforcement does,
here's what they claim to do
and they don't, y'all
make a decision community
but now you have access to it
in a way the law enforcement
usually has not provided.
The reason we do it that way
is in part because as a scholar,
it's difficult for me, I
mean, also with this face,
it's just difficult for me to
be in front of folks saying
let's get activated over X, Y, and Z.
That's not where my talents are.
But I have seen from
the inside growing up,
you know, from West
Philadelphia to the suburbs,
I've seen from the inside that
the temperature in the room
was it was making it impossible
for folks who would read on stuff
to get anything moved forward.
And so, the analytics make it possible
to turn down the temperature
and move things forward.
That's most of what we've done.
And in this moment, we're
excited to be moving
to decenter policing as
part of public safety.
That's what activists were able to do
in the last nine months that
I hope we don't go back.
You're on mute, there we go.
- Thank you for that Professor Goff.
So, like, you know, I know
you mentioned that CPE,
you know, has historically
worked closely with the police
and, you know, and as you
had friends sort of working
with inside the system,
and so, you know, I'm wondering,
you know, sort of how,
what led to that decision
and as you said how, you know,
has this current moment
shifted that to sort of
that de-centering in these conversations,
especially because as you know people
have grown increasingly
skeptical of sort of work
that works directly with police.
- So, I mean, I wanna push back both
on part of the opening framing
and part of that question
while I embrace it at the same time.
So, the reason and I'll start by answering
the question directly.
The reason I started working
inside a police department
is 'cause I got bullied into it.
That's not an excuse, I'm
not blaming nobody else.
I literally met a woman who challenged me
to instead of working
in laboratory settings,
I'm a social psychologist
by training, right,
and so for those of you who don't know
the discipline of social psychology,
our gig is that we lie to undergraduates
and then see what we do
and write papers about it.
Like I see people shaking their heads,
but like, no that's really,
that is a lot of what we do
and I never felt that was comfortable
for me to try and generalize
from, you know, undergraduates
who are at, particularly
at elite institutions.
And so I wanted to be out in the field
and she said, " Look, come
into the police department.
" Do the same stuff
out here in the field."
And she was coming out of a
town hall meeting a couple
of years prior to that engagement
where it was after the
murder of Paul Childs,
who was a 15 year old, not
mentally challenged black boy
who was, he was killed in his
own home in Denver, Colorado.
She went to a meeting
as a black woman police
at the time captain I
believe, went to this meeting
and had another black woman ask her,
"Do you train law enforcement
to kill young black men?"
Now I wanna be clear.
In a public context that's
a really easy question.
You say, no, of course not and
I'm so sorry for your loss.
The brave thing to do
is to actually take the
question seriously and she did.
She said, " I actually don't know."
So, she came to me and
said, I have this question
and nobody will try and ask it with me
or try and give me an answer.
And once you got in and
you saw what the power
of public safety was and
could be and I don't mean
that in the good way, when
you see the terrifying power
of police unions in these contexts
and the ways in which folks
who are set up to run municipalities
have no idea how their
systems of public safety work.
Folks who've had consent decrees,
so DOJ has come in, done an
investigation, adjudicated them
to have had a pattern and
a practice that was wrong,
and the local mayor still
has no idea how it runs.
It was not conceivable to me
that in my productive adult
years I was gonna see a country
where you could say, burn
it down, start over again.
So, the goal was to produce systems
that would point towards the need
to take law enforcement out of places
where they could not ever be
doing anything good, right?
The solution to homelessness
can never be a badge and a gun,
you better get a roof and four walls.
The solution like people talk about,
even now I'm seeing calls
for more critical incident training,
you cannot train law enforcement
to be the best first responders
to mental health crises.
You just can't do it.
It's the wrong tool.
But if you can't call for that directly
though you can say it out loud,
if that's not a productive political path
then what are the things
that allow for us to
move in that direction?
And actually tracking
racism in the same way
that they tracked crime
and allowing departments
to hold themselves accountable to that,
that seemed like a tool
that when every, like first
it was just do a study, give
feedback to a department
but in every city that was
fundamentally the thing
that the most radical activists
and the sort of everyday
traditional activists
were asking for.
Give us a way to know how bad it is
so we can hold them accountable for it.
And that's how we got it set up.
So, when you say that people
have become increasingly
or there's increasing, that
feels like a simplification
that I wanna make sure that
we get specific about it
'cause we have the space to do that here.
There is an ecosystem that
is rising that is ascendant
that has great and legitimate skepticism
of I think a broad range of reform
and having been in the space for a while,
I can tell you directly
as I said in '04, in '08
and in front of Congress
in 2010 and 2012, too much
of the folks working in
policing, it's a grift.
The folks who do implicit
bias training by and large
are doing, they get paid doing it,
they do not consult the scientist
though they incite us and the damn stuff,
and they don't wanna know
whether or not it works.
And the way I know is that
we've offered for free
to assess whether or not it
changes behavior in the streets
and folks patted on the head.
I literally got called boy
the first time I suggested
that that be something that happens.
But back when I had
hair is a long time ago.
So, that's fair,
but what's been happening
over the last four years
which is incremental and is
not aimed at the full scope
of the problem, it also hasn't
been scaled or tried honestly
and to lump those things
together to say that the folks
who are responsive to
what is still a majority
of community activists,
black folks who had diagnosed
the space as abolition is not possible,
what do we do to build so
that it can be possible
to lump that in with groups of folks
who are retired law enforcement
who's part of their processes
is to give money back into law enforcement
who make a profit off of doing it
and don't hold themselves accountable
to actual community goal.
That feels not just sort of not honest,
but it feels kind of dangerous to me
'cause I look forward to, not
like anticipation and hoping,
but I'm looking forward to a time
when the backlash is
weaponized against this moment,
and if we don't have the
tools to do the bold stuff
and the incremental stuff, I
fear we will walk backwards
'cause it's not like
the concept of abolition
and the concept of dismantling
the carceral state is new, right?
It is way more popular now.
It is way more mainstream now
than it's ever been before
and that's fantastic, but
it gets blotted out in part
because of weaponized white supremacy.
So, that's my pushback on that.
The last part of the question
was how it's changed stuff
and I mean, you said it in
reflection to what I'm saying.
We felt we had to do public safety
through the powers that existed
and we no longer feel
like that's the only path
and that is an incredible relief.
So, we have de-centered going
through police departments
to do our work as an organization,
and that's an exciting
path to be able to talk
about budgets out loud is
an exciting development.
It's an acceleration of the
work that we've been doing,
but it's accelerating like
I said, it's not possible
without the nine months
of street organizing.
- Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, I mean, thank you for that response
and I think the piece around reform
at least for me what's been helpful
is thinking about Mariame
Kaba and Critical Resistance,
how they frame reformist reforms
and non-reformist reforms,
you know, specifically reformist reforms
as reforms that provide more
resources, legitimacy sort
of capital to institutions in,
you know, make them more
permanent and expand them
and non-reformist reforms
that seek to reduce the scope
and sort of reliance and
resources around policing
in everyday life.
And so, that's how I try
to sort of tease that out.
And so, but you mentioned
the funding piece
and I know that CPE has released
a roadmap around funding
and I'm interested in the roadmap
and also if you wanna talk
more about the concept
for justice tool.
- Yeah, sure.
So, let me see if I can,
let me take Kaba to roadmap
to CompStat, does that work?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
So, I appreciate, I mean, in
all things I appreciate Mariame
but I appreciate the
distinction she's making.
I wish that we had a language just to talk
I think a little bit more honestly
about what that distinction
breaks down into.
And I'm not saying claiming
that she's being dishonest
in any way, shape or form,
but I don't think that talking
about non-reformist reform
and reformist reform cuts deep enough
to what the problems are.
There are people who position
and there are reforms
that position themselves at fixing things
with no theory of change.
They have no idea what it would look like
if they were fully successful.
It's just an idea to
be part of the process.
And those folks who say I
believe that this is the goal
and this is how these set of
interventions move us closer
to the goal, right?
That feels to me a little
bit more cutting nature
at the joints than these
two different blocks.
Now we can disagree about what the goal is
but there are folks who are serious
about I want my work to move
us in a particular direction
and they're folks who are much less so.
And as all things when you
have $115 billion on the table
there are way more folks
interested in getting paid
than there are folks interested
in making change, right?
But that to me is a
right set of distinctions
and one that's been going on in this space
for the folks who've been
doing it for a while, right?
I don't know that we're
capturing that right now
in this moment.
The reason why we put out the roadmap
in the way we did the roadmap
was, I think we put it out
in July and the reason was,
so there was the public
lynching of George Floyd
and obviously that sparked
huge unrest, hundreds of days
of protest in this country and
across the globe in solidarity.
And what happened shortly
thereafter, Minneapolis City
Council in collaboration
with activists in Minneapolis
who they by the way hadn't
been listening to previously,
they called for the defunding
which in the way that they did
it would have been a full dismantling
of their police department
and right before they went
on air to announce it,
how many had been
reported over the weekend
'cause they met on a Saturday?
Right before they went on
air to announce it on Monday,
they called and asked
if we would take part
and I said, look, if Messi
wants to do it, I'm with him.
Let's go.
So, they went on air and we went on air
and that night we got
I think 350 phone calls
from folks asking how.
And then for the course
of the next two weeks
they were in the 1500 phone calls.
There were police departments,
sheriff's departments,
state and local electeds,
activists looking
for a way to get there
and there was no way we had bandwidth,
you know, two years ago
we were an organization of 17 people.
We are as of today, I think
around 70, seven zero.
We're not gonna deal
with 1500 jurisdictions,
ain't gonna happen.
So, I'm thinking, what
is it that we can do
that can provide a map for the folks
who we're not working
with directly and closely?
So, we took the stuff that
we knew one should do,
that we would do that you
could give away combined
with the research that's out there
that would make some kind of sense.
I have a regret in that
which is, we worked with...
So, the five steps where
essentially, doing a 911 survey,
where people calling for police resources?
Second, do an officer discretionary survey
where officers go in
when they're not getting
directed by the public, right?
And that should give you a
sense of what are they managing,
like how are they engaging directly?
The third step I believe
was focus deterrence.
We gonna get back to that.
The fourth step was identifying the places
that were burdened either by crime
like so, by street violence
or by police presence
in the absence of crime,
'cause you can do that
if you've done the first two steps
and the fifth step is
essentially providing resources
in there.
We include a focus deterrence
'cause there's so much consensus
that it's fewer police resources,
that it should if it's done
the appropriate way
foreground community power
to identify the folks that are like,
these are the violence committers.
We wanna engage them directly
and it provides an off-ramp
for violence before
there's a punitive response.
I wish we hadn't done that.
The reason I wish we hadn't done that
is because it still relies on
law enforcement and punishment
as the root out of violence
despite the fact that there are reductions
to both of those systems
within focus deterrence.
I wish what we had thought of upfront
was the same thing, same
exact focused deterrence
but with universal basic
income instead of punishment
as the response which is
where we essentially (mumbles)
in four and five.
No excuses on that, like we
put out a public document.
I wrote the darn thing
along with Jeff Asher and other folks.
But the idea was to provide
a little bit of release val
'cause what we were hearing from people
when we said we can't get back to you
is like, okay, if you can't do it,
then we're just gonna wait.
We're just gonna do nothing
and when the country's on fire
we wanted folks to be able to take a step
that looked like a plan where
they could put some data
in front of themselves to calm themselves
so that they could do some things
that were significantly beyond
what they could have imagined
just a month earlier.
Not the perfect way to go but
that was the goal in that.
And you asked about concept
but I saw you take yourself off here,
you wanna ask me a question
before I get the cops out
or are you good?
- Maybe to, 'cause for folks who,
you know, might not know
about focus deterrence
I wanna just sort of, I think
you painted a good picture
and I just wanna sort of
like branch out even more
is like a large part is
sort of in that punitive
sort of approach is this
idea of pulling levers
and it's not only sort of individuals
but in the entire social networks
that people are sort of like a part of,
that are seen as part
of particular groups.
And, you know, the idea
is that if one person,
you know, engages in
violence at the entire group
will sort of, you know, will face
the sort of full scope of the law
and often they bring in state
and federal level prosecutors
in that work and so.
- So, let's drill down in that though
'cause that is bad
focus deterrence, right?
I'm saying, I don't think
we should have focus
deterrence in there at all,
but between Gary Slutkin
who has cure violence on the one hand,
David Kennedy has got National
Network for Safe Communities.
Pastor Mike, who does focus
deterrence out of what used
to be the Pico Network, there
are different versions of it.
That's the worst cop, where
you have a drag net for folks
who are connected in a social network
with an individual who
commits an act of violence.
The other forms of of
focus deterrence are,
you have a group of folks
who are prone to commit violence according
to past behavior, right?
They're in a network where
we should identify them
as vulnerable to violence
'cause that's really
the way that those networks are working
and you call them in, community calls them
and says, we know that you
guys are the most likely,
who are blinded by violence, if you do it
and you don't go these other routes
we're gonna call the cops on
you and you in particular.
Again, wish we hadn't done it
but that's a different
kind of focus deterrence
and it kind of says
everybody in the network
if one goes you all go which is, I mean,
that's unconstitutional and
gross in lots of different ways.
- Yeah, and I'm, you know, I'm glad
that part of what you mentioned
is sort of a shift away from,
you know, sort of a focus
on punishment to a focus on
sort of what does it look like
to assess needs and providing
resources as a model
as opposed to this sort of
intense sort of punitive.
But, you know, in terms of
the concept for justice,
you know, the specific
thing that I was wondering
if you we're able to talk more about
is sort of how poverty in reports
of crime becomes sort of
a part of the assessment
of whether in terms of police
deployment, sort of, yeah,
just talking more about what goes
into the metrics of
that concept for justice
and what that looks like.
- Okay, I definitely can explain it
but I'm not quite sure I
understood the question.
- Well, I guess if we can start by saying,
what is the concept for justice?
- Okay, so for folks who are
not in the policing space
you may have heard CompStat
and it has a terrible rep.
It has a terrible rep only
because it deserves it, okay?
So, what it is at its root,
what it was initially
meant to be, y'all know
how Target knows when you
and your partner get pregnant
and how Google knows
what you're searching for
and why you have to
clear the search history
'cause they looked at the pattern
and that was able to predict
what's happening going forward.
And the argument is you can
do that with crime, okay?
And you can to a degree, right,
look at past reported crimes
and say, these are areas
and these are individuals
who are likely to commit again.
Problem, of course, with that is,
and this is not minority report.
We'll get into like, if we want to
we can get into algorithm justice stuff.
Problems with that there is no such thing
as crime statistics, full stop.
That's not an ideological
thing that's scripted.
There's literally no such
thing as crime statistics.
There's reported crime statistics.
So, in New Haven, I don't
know this for a fact
but I'd be willing to bet
that the place that has the highest rate
of underage drinking is the dorms.
I'd also be willing to bet that the place
that has the highest rate
of what is still
considered illicit drug use
is the campus.
That's not me trying to
knock out the campus,
that's just saying any university town
that has got a university
is usually the site of the highest level
of what are still considered
illegal narcotics consumption.
But you don't see law
enforcement hanging out waiting
to bust up a dorm party.
We have decided that that's
not illegal in the same way
as the same activities are
in what's considered to
be an open-air market.
That's the problem with CompStat,
is that for the stats
folks it's indoctrinated,
you got the bias already baked in
'cause you're only stopping
black people in the first place.
Indoctrinated doesn't however
mean it's a useless tool,
it just means there are
the problems with it.
Beyond that, this is
now just a concept thing
and I'll explain why we get
the concept just a second.
Beyond that it started getting
used as a management tool
in a way that forget
about bringing down crime,
you had to contribute
to an increased number
of stops week over week, month
over month, year over year
to show that we're doing
anything at all, right,
'cause if we're not
driving the numbers down
then we're not doing anything
is the logic behind that.
Of course, that's ludicrous.
So, the green law enforcement
can do anything positive.
They surely can't do
the same sets of things
as appropriate education, healthcare,
employment, housing, right?
So, if they need to be the drivers
of get to get down to zero,
but at some point you're cutting corners
and you're just doing stuff that corrodes
the fabric of democracy.
That's why it has a bad rap.
But it's earliest idea is
that we can measure a thing
and hold ourselves accountable
to it and that helps.
And there is some evidence
that when law enforcement
holds themselves accountable
to crime, the crime goes
down not just through
the measurements of law enforcement.
So, not just through self-report
and that kind of mess.
So, the idea is since about 80%
of major city law
enforcement uses some system
like CompStat and I
think that number is low,
like the vast majority
of major city law enforcement
uses a system like CompStat,
it's part of the DNA of how
they do patrol and deployment.
Why would they not wanna measure justice
instead of just crime?
And if you can put it into the systems
in the same kind of way, right,
and give it over to communities,
so the community is
holding them accountable
not just for crime, but for disparity
and their portion of disparity,
you can dissenter crime
as the way that we talk
about public safety
and you can recenter
community values there.
Let me say this last thing
in terms of how this works.
All the folks who wanted to do the things
that are now getting called
for within law enforcement,
the police chiefs who wanted to
get officers out of public
health, out of mental health,
out of substance abuse, out
of the homelessness racket,
get them out of all of that stuff,
their biggest threat
is that crime goes up.
And what happens there is that
even in the most vulnerable communities,
they're like crime is up
what you doing get out
'cause we only hold police
accountable for crime.
There literally wasn't a
mechanism to hold them accountable
for something else statistically speaking
in a way that was easy and obvious
for electeds or for communities.
So, even in the communities
that their biggest concern
about law enforcement was racism,
they would call for the firing
of a chief in a crime spot.
So, the goal was to produce a product
that would allow for communities
to have a different metric
to change the conversation
and again, de-center crime
as the end all be all of what was going on
inside the law enforcement.
Now Phil you had a
question about the metrics,
maybe this is the right time to ask about
how the quantitative stuff works
and the theoretical elements,
that's where you were going.
- Yeah, so in terms of what
goes into determining, right,
like this is, sort of this
model of concept for justice,
how do you determine
if something is unjust
or like if there's patterns
in a particular area disproportionate?
- So it's a great question
and it's something
that I feel like the
public sort of face of this
does a bad job of explaining.
So, I appreciate getting a chance
to try and analyze it this way.
CompStat for just the way we set it up
is not designed to do the
best science possible.
It's not.
Here's what I mean.
The best science possible in
the traditional academic sense
and I don't even mean
the best science possible
what I would wanna do,
where that would be trying
to get real close down
to causality, right?
And we have no interest
in trying to reduce this to causality.
The reason being the data are so crappy.
We couldn't possibly do that at scale.
It's just not possible.
What we're doing is
descriptive statistics,
and what we're really doing
is disallowing one form of argument.
It is the most common form of argument,
so it's incredibly valuable
to my mind, just allow it.
If I'm a chief and you say,
look at these disparities,
you're clearly racist
and I'm remotely literate in this stuff,
I say, I'm not racist.
I'm going where crime is,
I'm going where poverty is.
We see it and we hear
it all the time, right,
like I had to spend probably
three weeks beating back
the dumbest analysis of
police behavioral data
in the history of christiandom saying,
there's no bias in policing.
Are you kidding me?
How do you do that this summer
for three f*ing weeks?
But it's partially because the argument
is so robust that people are like, well,
it does seem kind of
reasonable, just that.
So, if I take crime and
I take poverty, right,
and I take it off the table, right,
that doesn't actually, that's
not a good way of saying
that police don't
contribute to crime itself.
I actually have research
selling that they do.
It's not a good way of saying
the police don't contribute
to poverty, right,
I don't yet have that research in print,
we're working on that too.
But it does say shut up
about poverty and crime
as an excuse that it's not on y'all.
It takes it off the table.
And so, what CompStat for
justice is set up to do
is to say even if you were
right, and crime and poverty
are entirely out of your hands
and they don't overlap at all
with the things that you're
doing to communities,
if that were true this is the portion
that would still be you.
Do you have any arguments about that?
And in every city where we work,
they're like, oh I guess,
I don't, I hadn't thought
that you were gonna come
back with anything else
even though in every city we work, we do.
So, think about it in philosophical terms
as eminent critique.
I'm gonna take for granted
the arguments that you've got
and you're still full of it.
You still can't justify
that the racial disparities
that we see, they're not,
like poverty and crime
are not sufficient to explain them.
In fact, your policies and your behaviors
have to factor in at a significant level,
and at that point what you've done
is you've removed a bunch of the barriers
to public safety officials
being involved in change,
and you say, okay, so now we're
gonna be held accountable to that.
It raises the specter
that you could get in good
faith, folks getting that portion
that they're responsible down to zero
and you for sure will not
have not solved the problem.
I would love to get to that day
'cause we're nowhere near
in the most progressive
most liberal cities
that have the smallest
per capita police forces
and the largest and best teeth
around civilian oversight.
So, it's a tool to de-center crime
and de-center those arguments
in the production of public safety.
That's the way it was conceptualized.
- Yeah, and I mean, of
course, as you mentioned
that as we do know that there's, you know,
the problem of indoctrinated
that all those things
are sort of wrapped up in one another,
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, and my fear is
sort of like, you know,
with that as, sort of like
was learning more about it
is like this idea that if,
you know, police then say,
well, we solved this gap,
so we're only responding to, you know,
we're only going here because
it's this level of poverty
and this level of crime,
and it can reinforce
those sorts of logics that
they should be responding.
And so, you know, one of the things
that came to my mind was sort of
if there are alternative
ways to also sort of include,
you know, like if you're
responding to this
because, you know, these
levels of race or poverty
that this is also like unjust, you know,
and so, yeah, so it's (mumbles).
- Yes, so every city where we roll it out,
one of the nice things
is to be able to talk to folks, right?
So, they're like, yeah,
so we're only responsible for this 40%.
I was like, so first of all 40%
of a 15 to one disparity,
please don't smile.
That's not a good thing.
And secondly, you wanna claim the 40%,
this 30% that's you're
being driven by poverty,
I just wanna be clear
that you said out loud
you're okay to go and arrest poverty
'cause poverty should be punished
with the criminal legal system.
So, once you start saying it out loud,
you end up with portions of that disparity
that are pretty significant,
that are morally objectionable
to pretty much everybody
in the room, right.
Now, you could take it
and flip it and say,
the only thing you're
responsible is this portion,
let's get that as close
to zero as possible
and that's used to shut up any resistance
to the ways in which public safety
gets used to further
marginalized communities.
You absolutely could use it
to do that and you shouldn't.
But most of the tools that
I see that have broad,
in my mind have broad capacity
to reduce the footprint of law enforcement
are easily tripped up
in the exact same way.
So, I think what we have
to do is get real specific
on how we want the stuff to get used,
how we don't, get real loud
when it's getting used the wrong way
and talk about the ways in
which it's actually counter
to both the moral valence
that we wanna put on this
and the science on it.
I don't think anybody can justify 30%
of the racial disparity
here is driven by poverty
as somehow police are doing
the right thing, right,
like I don't think anybody
with a decent sense of just moral center
can make that argument out
loud once it's made clear.
So, there is the good faith
and the bad faith argument,
and then there's the appropriateness
of the tool towards the direction
that believe you and I are
trying to get together,
which is the full dismantling
of the state apparatus
that was put into place primarily
to regulate the liberty
of black bodies, right?
- Yeah, so, yeah, I mean,
let's, I know you mentioned
this before too and so
let's talk about Minneapolis
and sort of about a lot
of the progressive reforms
that were, have historically sort of been
at least politically attainable
and sort of that hadn't been implemented
in different places.
And, you know, CPE has
worked in Minneapolis,
in concert with the National Institute
for Community Trust and Justice
in the years leading up to 2020
and worked collectively into
another great deal of resources
to implement some of those popular reforms
of procedural justice, sort of
focus implicit bias training,
intervene policies,
reconciliation efforts,
focus on diversity and community policing.
And, you know, you shared
in the past that it's,
you know, at least
according to certain metrics
it's reduced particular
metrics of use of force by 18%,
but we all know in 2020
Minneapolis became the site
of an uprising over the
murder of George Floyd
that's spread throughout the country.
And so, you know, what
does it say about the,
you know, about sort
of these popular forms
and just we'd love to hear
more about your thoughts
in how to sort of situate that.
- Yeah, and so and here again I want folks
to do a closer reading of
what happened in Minneapolis,
really really do 'cause there is grift
that's been going on in Minneapolis
but there was an alarm sounded in 2015
about the culture in Minneapolis PD.
You know, it's, well-known Bob Kroll
who is the current union lead
what his affiliations are
in terms of white supremacy organizations.
It's well-known who did, and didn't go to,
and who abided by and
didn't abide by policy.
Let's go back to the
frame of the question.
You talked about popular reform
and you talked about
significant resources.
I wanna challenge that
because I think it's not accurate, okay?
In terms of resources, for
those of you who are asking
what he's asking about,
the National Initiative
for Building Community Trust and Justice
'cause DOJ named it and DOJ
is terrible at naming things.
The idea was to take three
things that we knew worked
in laboratories and see whether
or not it worked in cities
so that it could scale.
It was a pilot program, okay?
It's about $4.75 million which
I know I got humanists here
and that is a lot of money,
right, in the abstract.
Let me break down what that really means.
There were six cities over three years
across four organizations.
So, for quick math, it's
$75,000 per organization
per city per year.
That means each of us hired
one recent college graduate
and gave them bad health insurance.
That's functionally what it does, okay.
During that time there were improvements
in measures of public trust,
that's kind of an amazing thing
'cause we didn't do a PR campaign.
There was no, hey, look at
how much better we're getting.
Black communities in
particular felt their police
were less racist in the way
that they were being treated.
That feels like a really
good metric to me, right,
not just the trust, but
that they were less racist.
There were reductions in
some, but not all the cities
in use of force that were
proximately attributable
to some of the interventions
and there were reductions
in racial disparities
in that use of force.
It was a modest gain from a
massively underfunded initiative
which was by far the largest
investment in reforms
that had become popular, we
started in real time like 2016.
I think the grant was to 2015
but in real time it was 2016.
They had become popular the year before.
So, we talked about popular reforms
like stuff that was
popular for five years,
that's a long time in pop music
but it's not a long time
in terms of government
intervention, right?
They are popular now because
of the last five years
where folks are like, oh,
there's a thing off the shelf,
let's go do it, right?
They have not been funded,
they've not been skilled and to the degree
that they've been rolled out much
like community policing, right?
It started out as a thing
where you should have folks
in the community actually
policing themselves.
Community policing is
not a policing reform.
It's a community empowerment
reform at its base.
It got turned into, okay,
so we should have community,
we should have police in the community
and then it's, we should have a unit
that knows how to talk to folks
and dance off competitions
and be a PR campaign.
So yeah, if that's what
community policing is it's trash,
it's garbage, right?
I said from the beginning
that implicit bias training
by itself is everything
about that is a disaster.
As we were publishing and popularizing
and police (mumbles)
people, somebody, some idiot
is gonna turn this into just a training
and think you could just
do it, take it off the box
and be done with it.
We wrote that when we first
came out with the science.
That's not to say that you can't look
at the situations people are in
and try and reduce the
degree to which their biases
are informing their behaviors, right?
And then measure whether or
not the behaviors change.
So, what does it mean in
the context of Minneapolis?
The backdrop is these things
have been to the degree
that they're popular.
They've been popular for 15 seconds.
To the degree that they've taken money,
it's massively less than what's needed
to scale something like this
to see a kind of influence
especially in the context
of $115 billion industry.
But in terms of what it
means about Minneapolis,
I mean, I said this to you Phil
when we spoke the last time
in our pre-conversation,
if you do this work
and you don't get up every
day expecting to fail that,
I don't know that you're
right for the work.
But if you get up thinking
that these systems
that were set up to brutalize
the sons and daughters
of formerly enslaved folks
are gonna fall to you today,
it's kind of optimism that I think is,
it borders on irresponsible and dangerous.
I personally sent a memo
to the chief of police
in Minneapolis in end of March
beginning of April saying,
you know, you have a subculture.
- I think you're on mute.
- Oh no, I'm not on mute.
You can hear me now?
Okay.
So, I sent a memo to
Arradondo, the chief police
in Minneapolis, end of
March beginning of April,
you know you got, and by the
way we had stopped working
with them at that.
(Indistinct)
But you know, you've got a subculture
that is explicitly white supremacists.
You sue them including naming Bob Kroll,
the head of the police union, sue them
for racial discrimination
and one before your chief
and you have had no success
in rooting out that culture.
That means everything we've
done here can get flipped
in one incident.
Set that thing, right as
COVID was setting examples
'cause I was really worried
what we're gonna do,
is we were gonna criminalize
folks who were non-compliant,
which really meant
we weren't criminalized
black folks, right?
I didn't want law enforcement involved
in the enforcement of COVID regulations
and social distancing and
if we got to mask wear.
So, what it says about Minneapolis
is that it's like every other city.
There is no amount of inside game
that is going to fix
the mission of policing
which at the founding of this country,
when you first have law enforcement
was to regulate black bodies, right
and at no point in time
did we take an intermission
and say, " Okay, that was messed up.
" We should stop doing that."
There is no inside game
that's gonna do that.
It's what I knew going in.
It's what I know today.
It's why I'm relieved to be able to have,
I was the inside game to other
folks outside game, right?
I now get to be inside and outside.
That's a relief living
your life more honestly,
more directly.
But what I'd hope we don't do
is what I keep hearing folks say,
we now know reforms don't work.
To what end and with
which communities, right?
There are reforms that do the
thing they're supposed to do.
Ain't no reform that set up, right,
to fully dismantle tomorrow.
Performance harm reduction
and harm reduction is valuable
within a context.
We look to talk to any
public health person.
Sometimes the best you
can do is harm reduction
especially in the context of addiction.
And do I think that we're addicted
to a militarized public safety force?
Of course we are.
So, you can't tell me the
best thing going forward
is to abandon harm reduction
in service of anti addictions at work.
They have to go together.
The problem comes when harm reduction
is in the way of getting
us out of the addiction.
And that's what needs to
happen to reform folks
who are still in that
harm reduction space.
That's why, I mean, that's
what I think is going on
in Minneapolis right now.
They had us in there, we were out.
They asked us to come back.
They've asked us to come back again.
Now the process through the city council
has been very publicly not what
they wanted it to be, right,
'cause there's going to
need to be harm reduction
on the way to where we're going.
It just needs to not get in
the way of where we're going.
- Yeah, and that's something
I wanna sort of build more on it.
So, when you say in the way
what sorts of approaches
have you employed in
terms of CPE to make sure
that you don't get in the way
of those more sort of bold
transformative shifts?
- I'll say previous of this moment,
not enough probably, right
'cause previous to the moment
like I'm black, I'm from
Philly, graduated high school
with Muniz's son, the youngest son.
I've been in the space and doing this work
and screaming at police
chiefs for a long enough time
and nobody really questioned anything.
There are ways in which
folks who work internally
get in the way that, two in particular
that are incredibly damaging
that I feel like we did okay,
but we weren't as intentional
as we started being May 25th.
The two ways are, we call it
the shield and the offering.
So, there are communities where folks,
they take the roadmap
that CPE put together
and they're like, CPE said
this, we're gonna do this.
These are the experts.
Now we don't work there.
We had no conversations.
They just downloaded it from the website.
But there are local organizers
who are like, well, we
already did a 911 survey.
Are you just going to throw it out?
Like, yeah, yeah, we're
going to do the CPE way.
Yep, we already did that.
But essentially because we set it
for any national organization that set it
that has credibility outside
of whatever, small, local municipality
it gets used as the way to say,
hold on, not what you want,
what these folks know.
And so what needs to
happen in those contexts
is all of our materials are being revamped
going into 2021 to say we
cannot be used as a shield.
It's against the science, it's
against our ethics, right?
And we're working more proactively
with organizers in cities
where we don't work to make
sure that they understand
if we're ever used as a
shield, get us on the phone.
We will go on local television
and say, that's MBS, we're not with it.
That's the wrong way to use our stuff.
That's the first way.
That's the shield.
For off-ramp in some
ways is more insidious
and more dangerous, right?
It's part of like what
people will talk about
as a participation trap.
And Phil this is a problem
when you and I get together
it's not just a battle
of one L versus two L's
is that we're, this is inside baseball.
So, let me back up and do
participation trap, right,
so folks who are not in
movement spaces understand
that language and then I'll
go back to the off-ramp.
For those who are not familiar
with the term participation
trap is the idea
that you are standing in resistance,
you're protesting, you are
saying something needs to change,
and then that institution says,
" Great, let's do it together."
And you say, "Okay."
And by virtue of being in participation
of being in collaboration
with the institution,
the milk toast half
measure that is coming out,
your name somehow has attached to it
or they'll say, oh, well, they
weren't really collaborative,
they weren't really serious
so that even if the invitation
to participation is a trap
that derails the movement towards
the kind of progress
folks are trying to make.
That's the participation trap.
The risk for national
organizations like CPE
is that we will name a set of things
that this is where you can get to
and that becomes the final
destination for folks
as opposed to steps along the way.
And so, they say, okay,
we did what CPE said,
now we get be done.
It's a common problem
in negotiations politically all the time.
So, this summer, some of
you may have been following
the Justice in Policing Act
was put forward by a number
of Dems in the House, it
passed out of the House,
didn't get introduced on
the floor of the Senate
but there was great
consternation in hand-wringing
'cause it was eight
principles that were good,
they weren't abolitionists
by any stretch of imagination
but there were good.
They were gonna help something
and lots of folks wanted more.
And then there were other folks who said,
if we ask for that much,
it doesn't get to the floor of the Senate
and we'll get nothing.
What are you supposed to do?
Ask for all the things
that you want, right,
or negotiate against yourself
and guarantee that you get last stand?
The problem with national organizations
is because there are places
where we're not working.
We can be used as that off-ramp
to get less than what local organizers
have decided they want to push for, right?
And so, to articulate that as a principle
that we should not be in the
way of where local organizers
are ultimately going to
again work proactively
in the places where we don't already work,
to say you should use
our voice to push back
against folks trying to use science
to say, there is no
bias, training is enough,
training is anything in this space.
It's not nothing, but people use it like
it's the end all be all lever
as if individual officers
are the problem or God forbid
that these set of solutions
which we suggest are
useful are the end game.
But it is a hard thing to
do science in the abstract
in a world that isn't abstract,
to do science where we're
still fumbling towards
these are the right sets
of ways to quantify this
while people are needing
to make policy decisions right away.
So, there are gonna be times
when we are getting used as a shield,
and I hate to say this to all other people
who are in this space, you
too will be used that way
and as an off-ramp, and we
didn't get the attention to it
so we couldn't intervene to prevent that.
I don't think there's a
way to prevent it a 100%.
I think that what can be done
is we need to explicitly
say, don't do that,
don't use us that way
and then we need to devote our resources
to intervening when folks
are misusing our work
to be in the way that way.
- Yeah, so, you know,
recently in (indistinct)
you shared, I'm black man
centering black communities.
That means abolishing
systems of racial violence
and reforming public
institutions that can be made
to reflect the full
realization of black freedom,
is policing a system of racial bias
and needs to be abolished
or a public institution
that needs to be reformed?
- So, the easy answer for
me is it's the first, right?
The system that we have, nope.
The more complicated answer is then
what do you do with
community violence, right,
like this is the conversation
I wish we were having
amongst folks who are dedicated
to what I think is mostly common calls.
When someone is engaged in violence
who can intervene in a
way that can be trusted
when you're new in town, right,
When you're scared because your
abuser is also your beloved.
Who are the folks that intervene then?
Community violence
interrupters can be fantastic.
They cannot be everything.
When I talked to Erica
Ford about this stuff,
she like, I'm in that space
and we can't do all the things
that the community needs
to keep itself safe
especially 'cause we're not at a space
where there are the resources
to prevent so many of
those forms of violence
in the first place.
So, I am interested in what we
build up that isn't policing,
that isn't named that way,
that doesn't have that legacy.
I'm invested in helping
to figure that out.
That's what my science
has always been about
and will continue to be about.
And I feel like there's a
lot of ideological alignment
from all the folks across the spectrum.
I said, many of them,
(indistinct) on the end state,
but how do we get there?
How do we keep the most
vulnerable folks safe
between now and the there?
All the work that I've ever
done inside of law enforcement
was with the goal of
giving communities power
to decide how they were
gonna keep themselves safe.
I still stand by that.
As many mistakes as I feel
like I've made along the way,
most of the mistakes are
enrolled out in framing,
in relationship.
I still stand by the
science and the tactics.
But how we get from here to a future state
that centers the most
vulnerable communities,
gives them dignity and authority
to determine how they stay safe
and still allows for the fact that
in vulnerable communities
there will be violence,
I don't know exactly what that looks like.
And so, when we talk about re-imagining,
this is the imagination, but
I think we need to get to
our best Afro-futurists
like the abolitionists
that I was reading since
grad school, right?
They are able to talk about
things that don't work
and some things that do,
and I don't feel like
I'm all the way there
in terms of having a clear vision
of exactly what that looks like
and I know what it looks
like in the future state,
but what the transition, that
change management looks like
what we do between here and there
'cause I don't imagine a future
where there aren't public resources
to intercede when violence is out of hand.
I do see systems where
we don't have to treat
that like punishment is the only response,
but I don't see systems where
we don't have to intervene
in community violence
unless we're abandoning
those communities to themselves
which creates its own set of problems.
So, the short answer is it's the first
and the second answer
is I think way more complicated than that.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, you know, I think
the question of violence
is the one that often
comes up and, you know,
we know that police don't
sort of stop it sort
of in the ways and they cause
different forms of violence
until the question is it's
then sort of as you mentioned
is how do we build a, you know, presence
and sort of alternatives.
And I think there's a lot
of models that we have
that can be scaled up and others
that have to be experimented.
Other folks have said I think, you know,
there's a need to try
everything and change everything
as Mariame Kaba and Ruth
Wilson Gilmore had shared.
So, you know, we're
getting some questions.
So, let's ask this one from Jonathan.
He shares, you express pessimism
about the inside game based
around relationship management
with police departments
and noted that implicit
bias training grifters
are separate from social scientists.
I'm trying to get my hands
on more use of force data
but police departments have
no reason to give it to me.
I'm highly critical.
Would you or CPE consider committing
to sharing any data sets
publicly you acquired
through relationships with the
broader academic community?
I worry that if scientists
have to maintain good relationships
with police departments
to get data, it means police
communications jobs determine
what the public knows
about race and policing.
And this is similar to a question I had
'cause, you know, some folks
have have said, you know,
the national database that
we've all built is large
but it's not publicly
available and so, yeah.
- Yeah, and so I'm also seeing in the chat
the way in which we frame policing.
Policing is violence, right,
and also in black community
after black community
after black community,
you will find people
whose lives they say are still there
because they called the police.
Not police black folks.
Somebody on an interdict
right with violence
and if it's not police,
there is a lack of clarity
about what that would look like.
That doesn't mean I am in
favor of keeping status quo
by any stretch.
I'm just saying there needs
to be more specificity
as we move through that
and I'm for try everything
and, it's a both and, but
that changed management,
that's a beast.
So, to John, and I think
it's John (indistinct).
Okay, hey, how you doing?
So, in terms of sharing data
the way that the national justice database
got to be the largest
police behavioral database
in the world is that we
didn't require anybody
to share anything publicly.
Now to be clear we started
this right after Trayvon
Martin was shot killed, right?
There was no future state where I said
in my productive adulthood,
anything like that,
like open demand would be possible.
But it was also the case that
we were already seeing folks
who were using police data to
do really simplistic analysis
on both for, on behalf
of the police department
as if they were a stats PR
arm, folks who take money
from law enforcement which
in case it's relevant,
we do not for exactly that reason
but also scientists who were
just not particularly critical
or well-trained.
And so, what we wanted to do was we wanted
to make public not just
the data but the analytics,
and we had a of departments
who said, " No, thank you.
"We'll take this, we're super racist.
"That's scary, goodbye."
Other departments like
(indistinct) who made it public
but I think it made it easier
for the (indistinct) collective
to argue for the things
that they argued for, right?
Going forward now that
we're in this new state,
we are requiring that
any of the departments
that come in brand new
to us, and keep in mind
we have a backlog of about 250
but any of the new
departments and anything
that we're gonna fast
track coming up forward,
they must make the analytics public.
But to the degree that there's
been any kind of concerns
around this, I gotta say
I have not had a bunch
of folks reach out and say,
hey, can we collaborate?
I have these sets of questions.
Can I get access and collaboration?
'Cause there is no restriction
on us bringing collaborators
in, setting them up
and having them do their own thing, right?
We've reached out to folks
and said, hey, you've had
a lot of critical things
to say about this scientific approach,
are you interested in access to the data
that could disprove it?
And I am, I'll say I'm not surprised
that when we offer this to
folks who put out there,
it's scientific fact that there's no bias,
they don't want access to the data.
They just say the data are not public
and they're not responsive to our entries.
Please use our data to go ahead
and ask your same questions
with your same methods.
So, for social scientists
who are interested in
and who are hearing my voice, right,
we got our capacity issues, right,
we're still scaling up to make
our science team large enough
to be able to be responsive,
but come get some.
There's no reason for
collaboration to be off the table.
For the new folks, so the short answer
for the new folks coming in
we're requiring them to make that public.
Our MOUs require that we
can ask, we can encourage,
but we can't unilaterally decide
to make the old data public.
Let me say one last thing on that.
I started with, and I'll end with it.
If you just give disparities,
if you just give four
to one racial disparity
with the data, just
that simple descriptive,
and that's, by the way, that's nationally.
Police are four times more likely
to beat up black folks
than white folks, right,
just benchmarked on population.
If you just do that, you're
gonna get folks in the streets
they're like, told you they were racist
and you got to get law enforcement
who are like that's not
a reasonable analysis
and everybody's more entrenched
in their original position.
So, for everybody who
wants access to data,
I am in favor of democratizing data.
I want more data.
But I want, with the police
data in particular around race,
I want it to come with analytics.
I want it to come framed responsibly
'cause otherwise what you
end up with folks being mad
about what they came in thinking
and no ability for change whatsoever.
And I hate seeing science used that way.
- Okay, we have a question
around defund the police.
As we know, it's been sort
of used in various ways
by different politicians.
For political capital it's,
you know, also confusing.
Do you find the police
has just become a thing?
I know recently you shared,
you know, your thoughts that
if it wasn't framed in that
way, you know, things like
the surveys might've
not even been launched,
but I'm wondering if you wanna talk more
about sort of CPE's stand,
your thoughts around,
you know, defund the police
and the whole framing conversation.
- Yeah, I mean, I guess maybe I'll flag.
I'm speaking here not
fully on behalf of CPE.
CPE is a broader
organization than just me.
I get to be here as a professor,
at least I think I do.
My frame on it is, this is one
of those frustrating things
that I have ever seen in my lifetime.
How are Democratic strategists talking
about defund should have
been something different?
How, did anybody who was
talking defund when it launched?
Was anybody saying, and this
is an electoral strategy?
That's like people, like
Democrat strategist coming out
and saying, I feel like
McDonald, I'm loving it.
It is not helping people vote Democrat.
What?
They're not related.
They're not the same thing.
The goal of the rallying cry
was to make concrete, a set
of tactics on the other
way towards abolition.
It's a modest set of recommendations
to say money that you put
in towards public safety
should actually go towards
things that make the public safe.
And folks are arguing that
it's bad for electoral politics
because particularly
Democrats have not figured out
how to speak with fidelity
to black community issues
at the same time that they're
appealing to white centrists.
That is not activists problem
and it is mind numbing to me
that we have folks who
are yelling at activists
and I mean, the names and the
meanness and the nastiness
as of activist somehow are
supposed to be conscripted
in the same electoral project
as professional Democratic operatives.
That's just dumb, right, like it's just,
it's irresponsibly unsophisticated
and mind-numbingly illogical to me.
If you want to argue that defund
is a bad electoral message, great.
Tell politicians they
shouldn't say defund the police
which almost no politician
did by the way running
for national office,
but don't tell activists
that they should reframe the,
'cause they don't work for you.
I'd swear my earbud was fully
charged when we got started.
Anyway, the activists don't work
for the Democratic establishment.
And if the Democratic
establishment would like activist
to work for them, they
should give them money
and give them voice in
the democratic platform,
and until that happens,
they should shut the heck up
about what activists should be saying
that's obviously getting
activists, what activists
are trying to do.
Folks not doing the work
should not be telling folks doing the work
how to do the work.
It's not just defensive, it's oppressive.
- Yeah, you know, yeah,
thank you for that response.
And, you know, one of the things
that you sort of mentioned
sort of as you started
the response was that, you know,
there's you as a professor,
you as a person and there's you
as CEO of Center of Policing Equity,
and you know, some of the things
especially the more
transformative things that you,
you know, you've shared on
this call in this conversation,
how much of that gets translated to CPE
and sort of like what's the
interplay between the two?
- Yeah, it's a good question
'cause like at the beginning CPE
was just my research lab, right,
like I didn't call it nothing,
I just had a bunch of
undergraduates running
around recoding police data
that nobody had ever had
access to before, right.
So, it became a larger university thing
when I moved from State College
at Penn State out to UCLA
and then it was called
the Consortium for Police
Leadership in Equity
'cause I was bad at naming things.
But it wasn't even a
non-profit until 2017, right.
At that point it gets a
board and the board says,
you can take money from here,
you can't take money from here.
And at that point it is an
institution outside of me.
So, I'm a co-founder,
it's me and Tracie Keesee.
Our ideology, our politics
are pretty similar,
but the organization has a role to play.
And this is the thing that
I hope that folks get.
To get the kind of change
that I think again,
there's broad ideological commitment to
that abolitionists have been calling for
and that folks who aren't abolitionists
but have played abolitionists
in their spare time
but they call it for a long time,
to get that kind of change I don't think
we get there without an outside
game and an inside game.
I think there's going to be setbacks.
There's gonna be failures
that are really public.
I was really concerned
after that (mumbles) piece
I got published in The Times
and there was the podcast
around it about Minneapolis
'cause it framed it in
the worst possible way.
And so, the lane that
CPE is likely to stay in
for some time is going
to be straddling outside
and inside game.
I don't think you're
likely to see abolition
as the mission of CPE on its
website though, to be fair
and I know, it's going on YouTube
so I won't talk too bad
about CPE's website.
The website is gonna need some help.
It's in the works.
But I still don't think
you're gonna see it on CPE's website
'cause that's not the lane that CPE is in.
But I worry that we're in this moment
of real short-sightedness
in terms of the history
of this struggle.
I really appreciate that you put this
in the context of a long
struggle for black freedom,
and that we're throwing away...
I see stuff in meetings from
funders, from allies in this.
Well, we got white folks talking
about their abolitionists
and referring to black
women on this college campus
as agile model, getting
retweeted and getting lifted up.
I don't understand it.
There is a kind of venal toxicity
in portions of this space that are,
it's just counter to the goal.
So, CPE will likely to
continue to play a role
where it straddles the
inside, outside game.
We have had very little outside game
prior to nine months ago that was public.
I'm proud of what we've done previously
but it was less than 20% of what we did.
It's more than 50% of what we're planning
and likely even larger than that
in the next five to 10 years assuming
that it gets to exist
for five to 10 years.
But just because the tactics
and the lane are different
doesn't mean that they
have to be misaligned
and that's what I'm hoping we get to.
I hope we're talking more
about the appropriate responses
to violence that don't require punishment
that could require investment,
that we see violence as a
policy failure every time,
and that we're able to build coalition
across the various lanes 'cause
if we're making bold demands
and we got no body bringing
the middle along with us,
it's easy for that to just
break off and we get nothing.
And the one thing that makes me most tired
at all this is the number
of times that black folks
have gotten organized,
articulated very clearly
the ways in which this country owes
for our sacrifice, our
labor and we get nothing.
I don't, I'm tired of seeing that.
I don't wanna see that in this moment
and I don't wanna build things
that are likely to produce that.
- Yeah, we have a question
bringing it home to Yale.
I know that this is your,
you know, your first year
but, you know, I'm sure you do know
that there's been a campaign
on Black Students for Disarmament at Yale
and they've launched an
invest divest campaign
and yeah, and so, you know,
I'm wondering your thoughts,
you know, do you support
that sort of that work
and yeah, you know, a lot
of these conversations involve
different forms of policing
but the conversation's around other kinds
of besides municipal policing
like college campus police
as well as sheriffs, state troopers,
you know, federal police as we see sort of
in the Trump administration,
but thinking about college campuses
and yeah, what that looks like,
especially because, you
know, an organization
like CPE saying we support something
like invest divest at a
college campus, like yeah,
would carry like weight,
and so I'm just, yeah,
I'm wondering your thoughts
and how you relate to that all.
- Yeah, and so I got
to say, I am frustrated
at the scheduling of meetings
of (mumbles) section.
I've been asked to a couple
and I've had to not be able.
I just, the conflict was unavoidable.
So, I can't say that I know all
of the specifics of the tactics.
I will say I've been involved
in some conversations
across the campus about what it looks like
to abolish New Haven police
or what I hear more frequently
what it looks like to abolish
the Yale police department.
I am in favor of all
invest in black communities
and vulnerable communities
and take that money from punishment.
I am personally very much in favor of that
in every place that we can do it.
I think in the context of a university
it could be really interesting
'cause the real sort of contrary
audience here are parents,
and if you can get college
parents to get behind this,
then there's a lot of
models for what can happen
across college campuses, right?
Where it gets complicated to me
in terms of the local politics of it,
you take Yale PD and
you throw it out, okay.
As of right now I can tell you,
and I've now had conversations
with probably a dozen colleges
across the country, parents are saying,
that's all fine and good
but there better be cops
when my baby has a
complaint to make, right.
My baby better be safe
and I'm not re-imagining
nothing, right, I imagine
that if there's not someone
to call, I'mma sue you.
I'm gonna take all your money,
like your endowment's gonna be smaller
by the time I'm done with you, right.
And so what would happen, if
it's New Haven law enforcement
that comes in as supposed
to Yale law enforcement
that comes in, right.
When I go to Eastern parts and Fair Haven,
so I'm not living in New
Haven yet, I'm looking.
When I go to black parts of New Haven
what I hear in my quick
ethnographies, I'm seeing
we have somebody here who
spent time at barbershops.
Maurice is in here, right, when
I'm looking for barbershops,
what I hear is folks saying,
they noticed the demonstrating
in Yale at New Haven.
They'd rather get stopped by
Yale PD, the New Haven PD.
And so, is the goal a
reduction in New Haven
or is the goal a destruction
of Yale PD and an expansion...
how does it get done?
And so, what I'm interested
in and what I'm hoping
will be part of the conversation
when I get to engage with the undergrads
as well as the graduate
group and increasingly
there's a faculty group
that's interested in this,
what is the invest part?
What gets stood up, at what
pace with what investment
and how do we then
message the ways in which
that can allow us to divest
from structures of punishment?
University of Pennsylvania
just committed a $100 million
to Philadelphia public schools, right?
That is a great PR campaign.
I'm really interested to see how
that money gets actually invested, right?
But if U Penn can do something like that
what is Yale prepared to do
to make sure that particularly
black residents of New Haven
are positioned to be safer
without the need for law enforcement?
That's the part that I'd...
So, I'm generally endorsed
and favorable to the position.
I would very much like
to sit down and talk
and to the degree
that I can be useful
advocating, hell yeah.
All of my conversations so
far, every university has been,
how do you put university
police out of business?
And if that is not your goal
then I would suggest you
get a different goal.
- We have a question from Damarlos
which is similar to some of the things
you were just mentioning
and that I brought up in the question.
He says violence is not the
only community safety concern
facing black communities.
Cities and government officials often talk
about addressing social
inequalities in the abstract,
but are unwilling to actually change
their investment strategies
or policy priorities
to realize those changes.
From your perspective, how
do we shift conversations
about community from solely
focusing on eradicating violence
to focus on sustaining
social determinants of health
and eradicating persistent
social inequalities?
Is CPE actively working to
shift the narrative in this way?
- Yeah, and so I wanna do a both end here.
Thank you Damara as
always for coming correct.
I want us to talk about violence
because I want us to understand
if we let out everybody
who is incarcerated right now
or was on state monitoring,
gets non-violent, we got what?
3/4 of folks still left locked up.
I want the big changes and
if we don't reckon with,
I mean, it is hard now
not to be responsive
to Danielle Sered's book,
right, "Until We Reckon."
But we don't reckon with violence,
I worry we're not gonna
have the tools that we need
and at the same time violence
is not the only safety
concern, absolutely.
I am less interested
in decentering violence
than I am in expanding the center
to talk about what communities
are interested in talking about.
But I'll say in addition that when I go
and I'm listening to community meetings,
when I was walking around in New Haven
and talking to folks I
was like, hey, so what
does it mean to be safe here?
I had real interesting
conversation as my wife and I
were house on it, probably
what does community safety here mean?
It ends up being either deeply abstracted.
I mean, the conversation
was just leave us alone.
Just let us be.
I wanna walk around and know
that it's nobody's right
to stop me.
And I was like, oh, I'm sorry.
I don't mean, he's like, no,
no, I'm good talking to you.
I just like, I know I could walk away.
That's kind of abstract.
The other things that I hear
end up being low level quality
of life things and it'd
be great to focus on...
That's, I don't want that in
the public safety conversation,
the quality of life stuff I want
in the public health conversation.
So, the way it's, we just
had a meeting yesterday with,
I don't know if you guys
have been following American
Medical Association,
just put out a list of principles
they call white supremacy
and police brutality
as white supremacy a
public health problem.
We've been working with them
for a minute trying to get that out.
I'm so excited and proud
that the American Medical Association
has a statement on police
brutality as public health issues.
We've been working with
Robert Wood Johnson
and other funders
to make public safety
a public health issue,
and to take public health,
allow that to segment out
the things that police
shouldn't have been dealing with
in the first place.
So, that's behind the scene stuff.
It's not part of the public portfolio.
I think we'll be messaging about that.
We now have a brand new director
of public health at CPE.
We'll be messaging about that.
But I think the longest route,
if I can make my answer
a little bit simpler,
the longest shot is I
want to center violence
and public safety 'cause I
think that's a conversation
we need to be having
and way more concretely.
And I wanna take most of the other things
that kind of are public safety
and remove them from that
and put them in public health
'cause a public health response
will be radically different
than a punitive one.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah.
Yeah, thank you for that response.
And so, I wanted sort of, and
we're nearing towards the end,
but one of the things that
I did wanna ask you about
is sort of, you know, as you shared
with the previous question
that you sort of imagined
abolitionists horizon,
but I know in a CNN article
from a few months ago,
you seemingly argued for limited
but viable role for police.
And, you know, you said
that suburbs are an example
of what that can look like.
And so, I'm wondering,
because those things seem,
you know, a bit different, I'm wondering
if you can talk more about
that sort of, and if, you know,
in that model sort of
what you imagine police
should be involved within that context
and sort of I'm hearing
a bit of a disjunction,
so I'm just wondering about that.
And also, you know,
suburbs are also, you know,
they seemingly seem like,
you know, sites of not police officers,
but when you go and, you know,
there's often black
models in those contexts
that do experience routine racial,
you know, racialized police
violence discrimination.
But yeah, I'm just interested
in hearing more about that.
- Yeah, so we published that in the midst
of sort of the ground shifting under feet.
And so what I was trying
to do in that article
was to make the idea of reducing
the size of law enforcement
and increasing community
control less exotic
for the hundreds of
mayors and city councils
who were reaching out to us,
like this does not have to be scary.
And I can't do that by making reference
to Afro-futurism and the
long history of abolitionism
within black intellectual tradition
'cause they're not trying
to hear any of that.
So, the talking point was,
have you been to a suburb?
The footprint of law
enforcement is less per capita.
If anybody in the community or any group
within the community is outspoken enough,
it changes tactics, right?
It is much more Mayberry than
what we get in urban policing.
And that was mostly for the urban folks
who were being responsive to that.
Now, I don't know whether or not
it made it into the final draft,
but I did have a section saying
that is, of course, only if you live there
'cause if you're passing through
those are terrible sites of violence.
And what we know is that in
smaller police department,
the smaller it gets the higher
the rate of deadly force.
In part they'll argue
because of lack of
training but regardless.
So, the idea is to start making
a new world more familiar
to folks who've got the ability
to make those decisions.
I still think that that makes sense
as a talking point to
a particular audience.
I don't use it in most
of the conversations
that I'm having right now
for exactly that reason,
'cause we think of suburban
as a cookie cutter.
We think about it as only white
but black people live
in the suburbs, right?
There's great diversity within suburbs
especially depending on how
they're set up and drawn,
I mean, so within suburbs you
have massive stratification
in the same way that
you do in urban areas,
it just looks different in
terms of the experience of it.
But that was just the goal
is to make a future state less exotic
for the people who were trying
to make moves in August.
I think that's when they came out, August.
- Yeah, August September.
Yeah, I mean, I think we're at about time
and, you know, again I thank
everyone for coming out today
and engaging in this conversation with us,
you know, and I hope if
nothing else it's brought,
you know, a sense of
clarity around, you know,
the conversations around
race and policing.
I mean importantly, you
know, I think there's,
you know, to acknowledge
that there can be,
and I think clarity envisions
can be formed through struggle,
and, you know, I think there
can be sometimes an attempt to,
you know, push and try to
say, you know, everyone
is saying the same thing
and things like that
but I think it's important
to hold, you know,
when people are saying different things
and hold the complexity and
have, you know, conversations.
And I hope that we can continue, you know,
these conversations and yeah,
thank you everyone for coming.